if you can put on your wise sage hat
and give some advice to young people i
mean
you know the past four hours have been a
kind of advice but if you can
focus and if somebody in high school or
college is thinking about
what to do with their career can have a
successful career or to have a life they
can be proud of what would you tell them
i'd say probably the most important
advice that i would give is to find a
way to
give value to other people and this is
really the key thing you need to wake up
every morning and figure out how to
serve others this is
this is the key to everything you want
in life everything that you want is on
the other side of you serving others so
figure out how you can serve others in a
good way
how you can do it in a way that they
value and you've got an incredible
mechanism for figuring that out which is
the market
go out there and do things for other
people and you know the market will tell
you the market will tell you exactly if
you're young you have the enormous
advantage of being able to make things
make mistakes essentially and learn from
them
so
go out there do things of value for
others figuring out how you can do
something
that pre-contribute what is it that you
can do that contributes the most value
to other people's lives
and increasingly i think with the modern
technology this is increasingly becoming
online and it's uh
i think you know you should consider how
you can
create value online because that sca
scales
beyond anything that you can do in the
physical world in a very very uh well
maybe not beyond obviously there are
profitable businesses in in
in the physical world but i think online
is enormous potential
and coding i think is enormously
powerful i'm not a coder myself but i
strongly recommend people get into
learning how to code and i think it's
it's it's probably the thing that
carries the most uh
power so initially we were working with
our hands we started working with
machines machines are much more
productive well code is an even higher
level of productivity where you
basically program the machines to
produce things so
um you know few clicks of a keyboard and
you can move millions of machines around
the world in certain ways so it carries
an enormous amount of value i think um
i always tell all young people to learn
to code it's the best thing
i used to tell it to my students when i
was at university i tell them to drop
out and go learn to code it's probably a
better use of their time and money we
could probably do both
yeah university has an interesting
function i mean
probably you and i have different
perspective on this probably has to do
with a little bit of a different journey
in terms of um
fields because i'm so
i've stayed engineering focused for a
long time and there's less some of the
troubles you might highlight in the
education system there's less troubles
of that kind
in engineering because
math hasn't changed for a long time so
yeah it's a lot of it is just doing hard
things being forced to do hard things
and becoming a bit of a journalist while
on the side you're also becoming a
specialist
based on your own passion by your own
passion so school
at least high school i don't know about
the university but
high school
that's a really nice
one of the only times in your life at
least in my life
i was forced
but now i see
uh given the opportunity to spend my
entire day learning
broadly
and that's something i don't know the
way time works it just runs away from
you you never really get a chance to do
learn quite that broadly
again
that's the curse of specialization is
you kind of
never get a chance to study biology
chemistry if you're a physicist on you
know time runs away from you so it's
enjoy the the broad
uh the broad education of it but yeah
like you said
find the things that
valued by the market
and on the other side of it you said all
the good stuff so that's also a way to
get happiness
yeah and i'll also add the horse that i
like to whip all the time is the low
time preference aspect of things saving
with bitcoin so i think my advice to
young people is you know when you're
young you think of the world in the very
short term generally you're focused on
the present and you think that
everything that's happening in the
present is the most important thing
that's ever going to happen in the
history of humanity
lower your time preference think about
the future think about think further
down the line think about the
consequences of the things that you do
and then what you know and so you do
this now it feels good today but then
what happens tomorrow you know you go
out you drink you enjoy yourself well
think about the hangover but more in
long term think about the implication of
living this kind of life
think about every decision that you make
the long-term implication of it and part
of that is bitcoin part of that is um
save in bitcoin i urge everybody to put
savings in bitcoin for the long term
don't buy bitcoin for the short term you
know don't buy bitcoin today so that you
can sell it you don't put your savings
in bitcoin today so that you can sell it
all next month and buy a house
put money in bitcoin that you expect to
keep in bitcoin for another
five ten
years or so at least four years is what
i recommend for people so keep a low
time preference focus on the future and
saving bitcoin and uh learn about how to
buy bitcoin how to learn about all this
technology part of this is this
conversation but there's so much awesome
material out there and thank you by the
way for this gift of a hardware wallet
nice uh so you should definitely invest
in it yourself and uh
what would you call this these are open
dimes open dimes yeah so this is like
usb that you can like a hardware device
that stores bitcoin yeah so you don't
have to worry about us
knowing the passport it contains the
password within it and it's tamper-proof
so you can save the bitcoin on it and so
when the apocalypse comes
you need the the value to be stored an
actual thing that you can have in your
physical possession yeah that's exactly
what this is
you